I grew up in Greenfield Indiana a small
hard-working farming community where the
majority of people have the mindset that
you have to be in debt in order to be
successful so when I had the opportunity
to have the Foundation's class in high
school I learned that that's not
necessarily the case you don't have to
go into debt in order to be successful
so this is my classroom where I took the
Foundation's class in high school about
four years ago I sat right over here
where mrs. Graff taught us exactly what
the different principals are so that we
can stay out of debt and one thing that
really hit me was that I could graduate
college debt-free to three months ago
she contacted me by text and she said I
just wanted to let you know that I just
graduated college debt-free
and it was just wonderful to hear that
the kids are behind what they've learned
in my class I did a lot of Pet Sitting
type of jobs I had an account
specifically made that was for college
and I thought almost all of it in there
I went in with leave I had seven
scholarships I applied for fifty-two
while I was in high school and then I
had a couple that waited and they would
only give it to me once I finished my
first year and then that's when we
started kicking in some of our savings
when we talked about how you can go to
college debt-free they again don't
believe that that's not possible I need
to get lots of loans and so it's really
cool to see their faces light up when it
starts to click in and they can see that
oh my gosh
this is reachable I can do this and then
when I get kids that come back and tell
me how successful they've been that's
like the ultimate by taking foundations
in learning those skills and getting
that valuable knowledge I can be
whatever I want to be I don't have to be
restricted to whatever the first job
comes my way I can afford basically to
be choosy so I think it would be really
great and beneficial to all students if
they could be taught foundations class
and really
basically get that foundation of
finances and how to be smart with their
money so that way when they go into
college they can build those habits
there that they can then use in their
life once they get out of college and
continue that streak of seeing debt-free